somebody who will know is Mick Lynch
Secretary General of the rmts with us
now hello to you Mr Lynch just
confirming
um those strike days so you've got
tranches before and after Christmas
yes we have we've got uh blocks of 48
hour strikes and an overtime ban between
um we've not made the progress we would
like in the discussions
we feel that the government is blocking
the uh a path to a settlement because of
their intransigence we haven't had a
strike for a considerable time now to
allow for those talks but we haven't
made any progress we've got no Auto for
the train operating companies and we've
got no new offers from Network rails so
we have to try and uh push this along to
get towards the settlement so
unfortunately we have to take this
industrial election
uh we've tried to keep that away from
the Christmas week itself and the
festive period so that people can travel
and make their Arrangements yeah
government's blaming you what would you
say in response
well that's typical the government is in
charge of the railways the secretary of
state has got a contract with the train
operating companies that he is
responsible for industrial relations and
he directly sets their mandate in
negotiation so he's the person that's
controlling them gives them their
instructions and of course he's the only
shareholder in network rails so he's got
direct responsibility and I'm calling on
him and I'm meeting him tomorrow to be
somebody that facilitates the deal
facilitates progress rather than being
somebody that obstructs it I don't
understand why they've canceled around
the negotiations and have canceled an
offer that they were formulating over
the weekend and we're going to put to me
at two o'clock on Monday and cancel the
meeting with less than an hour's notice
so I I'm not quite sure what the
government's up to but they've got a get
off their hands and get get working on
getting an agreement you were in I think
I'm writing saying in in quotes intense
negotiations of fortnight ago what
happened
yes we were so we sat down uh two
strands of network Rail and the train
operators we've had office from Network
rail which have not been acceptable and
we'll continue to work with them on
those to see if we can get an improved
offer but with the train operating
companies that people run Great Western
and Avanti West Coast and Nar and all
those big outfits we've never had an
offer in six months they've never
written to us with a document they've
never set out their proposals in writing
them formally they told us on Friday
that they couldn't do that because
they'd been prevented from doing it by
their by the authorities which is the
government they then told me on Saturday
that they would make an offer at two
o'clock on Monday afternoon and we knew
what was coming
um but they failed to to deliver they
have not put anything in right and there
is no offer for us to consider now after
six months we can't just keep going at
this uh in a part-time way we've got to
get progress we want our members to get
back to work we want them to have job
security we want the to secure their
conditions and make agreements with the
company about the future of the Railway
and we'd like a pay rise which we
haven't had for two or three years on
the railway we've been subject to a pay
freeze so I think the employers know
what they need to do to make progress
but they're being stopped by an unseen
hand the person who's not at the table
but a person they have to go back to
every day when they're getting a German
at a break they have to go back and
report to the government and the
department for transport officials and
they've been prevented from making an
appropriate offer okay so you say you
haven't had an offer for six months we
spoke to network rail they said today
yesterday we put a new payoff on the
table for our rmt colleagues which will
be worth over five percent conditional
on achieving savings through modernizing
reforms there's also money on the table
for a fair and affordable deal for next
year too
um is that all right
well I Put A variation of an offer they
made before which they know is
unacceptable they would accept that
across the table with me and my officers
they know that the stuff they put down
is not acceptable they've tinkered at
the edges but it remains four percent
for this year and four percent for last
year and nothing for for next year sorry
and nothing to last year when we've got
no pay rise so it's it's an eight
percent deal over three years that
they've offered but the conditions that
they want to put down are unacceptable
uh nearly 2 000 job losses and a set of
conditions that our members find
intolerable and we've we've breached our
reps on that over 600 people on mass
meetings and they've told us directly
they don't want to accept that so
they've got to come up with something
new a new uh package of change that
we'll work with them on and a new paper
puzzle because at the moment is just not
acceptable and they know that already
and they know they've got to make a
substantive move but as I say with the
train operators there's no uh offer
whatsoever
um I mean you're a union man through and
through you know that a lot of people in
hospitality and also
um you know working in shops and
businesses will be hugely in they're
trying to get back on their feet after
the pandemic hugely impacted by these
strikes is it really the right thing to
do at this time of year
well there's never a right time to go on
strike we don't want to be on strike and
we have taken quite a lot of care over
the last six months and have listened to
public opinion uh and groups that have
contacted us and we have moved our
strikes around to accommodate as far as
we can but after six months and two
ballots where our members have delivered
mandates twice despite the anti-union
laws that we've got in this country we
need to get this finished and get it
over the line so when people break
promises that they'll put new offers on
the table senior people in the industry
and then they're prevented from doing
that by government officials and
transport Department officials we have
to respond to that and there is a strong
call from our membership to escalate
this action as we've done which is
unfortunate and we do apologize for the
disruption this is causing but you're
going to find this across society and
across sectors and many Industries where
workers are saying we cannot tolerate
what were the prescription we've been
given by the government and by the
employers where their wages are being
driven down their work is being made
insecure and their conditions are being
ripped off them in the name of profit
and the accumulation of wealth by the
super rich which is what is happening in
this Society so we need a change and
we're determined to get a deal on behalf
of our members and we're sorry
yeah Azure time almost just want to ask
you very quickly so you feel that you've
got the support of the public for these
uh transfer strikes over Christmas in
the new year well we've had public
support so far quite strongly we we
understand the difficulties and we will
be trying to communicate our case to the
public through whatever means we can but
we know it's a tough call and we've been
careful not to actually disrupt the
festive period so our last strike Before
Christmas is on the 17th that gives
people a full week to wait to make their
arrangements and we won't disrupt
through strike action the period between
Christmas and New Year and the
resumption of normal business after
Christmas so that's what we've done we
know that's not palatable to some people
but that's where we are at the moment